now as you draw your big set of axes
there we should put some important
labels on it and underneath your new big
set of axes I want you to think about
this guy with me now this is an equation
we've seen before right at the beginning
of this topics before we looked at
graphs in fact these are with a
particular kind of problem do you
remember we're talking about
proportionality or variation and there
were two clones there's like when you've
got two quantities and they both go up
together like say for instance the
example I gave you was money and
doughnuts I always come back to
doughnuts that's just the way my brain
works so when one thing goes up the
other goes up but there was another kind
of proportional variations remember what
it was it was inverse or indirect one
goes up the other goes down and what was
my example more people means less than
up to a person see everyone can talk in
Donuts okay
now this guy here do you remember this
guy is that second kind if for example X
was the number of people in the room
then as X gets bigger Y gets smaller
less less Donuts right it becomes like
1/2 1/3 1/4 you're just getting smaller
and smaller pieces every time so what
does this look like I could ask you to
draw up a table of values it would you
know be quite long because we need a lot
of value to you but I wonder if you can
just help me plot some points directly
on here it's really simple for instance
it's actually equal to 1 X is equal to 1
then Y would equal to 1 over 1 which is
1 so if X is 1 Y is 1 let's put that
point on our coordinate axes so I'm
going to call that 1 1 okay don't worry
about labeling it with the coordinates
yet because your diagram is going to get
super busy in a minute so we'll just
leave it off for now what about as X was
2 y would be equal to 1 over 2 which is
1/2 right so when X is 2 you see I've
gone over right Y is what you just said
you just told me that Y would be 1 over
2 which is 1/2 right so here's 1 our 1/2
would be there wouldn't it it's lower
isn't it so
something like that you see that so this
is kind of like people people and this
is donuts right and I'm getting less and
less when actually equal to three you
can see the pattern that's why I'm going
to be equal to 1 over 3 which is 1/3 so
where would a third be maybe someone
like there there okay now it's
interesting it's interesting you can see
if I keep going I'm going to get 1 1/2
1/3 the next one would be 1/4 1/5 1/6
etc
am I ever going to get to 0 why not so
so have a look you can focus is a really
important point especially for those of
you considering to unit or other courses
like that next year because these kinds
of things we have up these kinds of
things are called functions we have a
lot a lot of time to spend on those so
I'm just mindful of you understanding it
for the future that's better
no matter how big you make X you could
make this a million a billion a Google
whatever large number you choose you
guys know that's actually a number right
that's anyway that's what Google's named
after Google's named after the number
long story no matter how big you make
that number one over that will never be
zero so this is a weird interesting
thing it gets closer to zero but never
actually arrives so here's what you need
to do I'm inclined to agree when you pen
in hand we're going to draw something
weird and different that we never put on
anyway graphs before onto this set of
axes to try and capture the fact that we
get closer and closer and closer but
never arrive take your pen pencil and
draw in a dotted horizontal line either
on top if you can see it or just above
the x-axis
now this dotted horizontal line close
it's right on the x-axis we know it's
equation does anyone know what the
equation of that horizontal line will be
it'll be y equals y equals zero because
where are you up and down that's what Y
is answer you're not up and you're not
down you're exactly in the middle that's
y equals zero this guy's really
important you need a new color for this
this guy is called an asymptote that's a
weird word but what it's talking about
is this behavior of getting closer and
closer and closer but never arriving
okay so in fact I can sort of complete
what's going on over here maybe you've
already done that and you can see the
shape just like all of these guys here
is curves but it's a different kind of
curve okay it's getting closer this
crushing but never quite for reaching it
okay now we were just sort of plugging
some numbers in here what happens to the
left what's going on what if X were say
a half if X were a half what would Y
equal let me write it if X is 1/2 then Y
is equal to 1 over 1/2 what is that
that's two right in fact this thing it
just takes the reciprocal every time
right so Y is going to be equal to do
well where is that that was x equals 1
so x equals 1/2 is here so y equals 2
will be up here like that junus that
what about a X is equal to 1/3 X is
equal to 1/3 then Y will be 3 so when
you go in a closer to the origin then
you're going further up like this now
this should make you a bit suspicious
right because this kind of shape here is
exactly the kind of shape you observed
over here but just sort of rotate it
around like sort of 90 degrees so in
fact you can finish off what's going on
like that now over here we could play
this game of putting in larger and
larger numbers of X right and seeing
what happens and imagining but when you
try and go to the left you run into this
problem because there x equals 0 that's
what you would do to find a y-intercept
what happens when X is equal to 0
so so this guy sure someone's going to
reach for their calculators there's
matter what does that mean this guy
blows up I will show you why it blows up
because not just some rule that a
mathematician said I've decided that
this blows up you know and some smart
guy decided we all agreed here is why
okay Shima mean something like say 6
divided by 3 what is 6 divided by 3 it's
too the reason why we can see this is
because you can equally say that 6 is 2
times 3
do you agree right and this is like how
you deal with equations I've multiplied
both sides by 3 that's how I go from
here to here is that ok
right now let's imagine right so 1
divided by 0 is some number and I don't
know what it is right
so only I had a branch of mathematics
that was dealing with numbers when you
don't know what they are oh wait I do
it's called algebra so I'm going to give
this a label right let's call it n for a
number and I don't know what this number
is
well if Nichkhun is going to play ball
this is going to work with the rest of
the rules of mathematics I should be
able to do this thing right remember I
did this I multiply both sides by 3 up
here so down here I'm going to multiply
both sides by 0 I should get 1 and then
what I get on the right hand side well
one of the things you know about 0 is if
you multiply anything by 0 you get 0 so
what this is telling you is but this
this can't make sense because one can
never equal 0 so that's why this blows
up that's why your calculator says that
there are because it's running up
against this reality so what does it
mean so this graph here X can't equal 0
that means remember this dotted line we
drew at y equals 0 you've got a dotted
line to draw at x equals 0
so you get another asymptote and because
I put this line on here I want to know
what line it is so I'm going to label it
x equals zero okay so this is a weird
kind of shape it's it's quite different
to all these other ones right even
though it has similarities now I'm not
quite finished I know exactly what's
happening over here on the right hand
side is there anything happening over
here on the left-hand side how would I
find out what did I do to get these
things what did I do
I just tried putting numbers in right I
plotted points you can do the same thing
over here when X is equal to negative
one what will y equal Y will be one over
negative one which is itself negative
one so you can put that on country what
about x equals say negative two x equals
negative two yeah Y is going to be think
about it Y is going to be 1 over
negative 2 which is negative 1/2
negative 1/2 this sounds familiar
doesn't it in fact it's exactly the same
shape you got over there except it's
being rotated around okay you've just
drawn the whole shape this this what you
just created is my scales a bit off but
I'll leave it for now because mostly
okay this is the hyperbola okay do you
remember when I asked you to draw these
for graphs to review I pointed out
something about their symmetry do you
remember that right this kind of
symmetry was it's called reflection all
right and it went with what kinds of
powers of X what kinds of powers even
two four six eight they'd all look the
same
okay this is not reflectional symmetry
it's rotational symmetry right so if you
took your page you just spun it around
you get the same thing
what kind of symmetry does it have
now this is interesting right this guy
seems to have both but in a particular
kind of way
you can't tip it across this way genus
that hunt whoops you can't flip it
across vertically right yeah you've got
to flip it or you've got to sort of look
at it at 45 degrees and flip it this way
now did you notice that a better way to
say it without having to turn your head
is you can just take this guy in fact
take your page
take your page now and just like like
was x and y equals x cubed spin your
page upside down so you've rotated 180
degrees and you can see it's still the
same hyperbola okay so if you've got
another color their key please right you
have rotational symmetry here which
should not surprise us that much because
look carefully at the powers look at all
of the winner for my black one there is
look at the powers of our reflection li
symmetrical graphs over here three
what's the power here one I didn't write
it like that but it is actually a power
what's the power right all right so of
course it's we X to 1/2 is something
else will comes out a bit later this is
minus one right which clearly is you see
the pattern right it's sort of it's an
odd number isn't it we don't usually
think about odd numbers with negatives
but three one negative one they clearly
made it the same DNA okay so I think
that's just a really nice feature of it
that you should see even though it's so
different it's it's made of the same
stuff